Il y a un accessoire de mode qui est hyper sexy...
C'est les chaussettes.
Faux !
Je ne peux pas te laisser dire ça, Alan.
Tu as tout faux.
Les chaussettes, c'est ce qu'il y a de moins sexy au monde.
Je sais Steven, c'était de l'ironie.
Mais bien sûr...
Tu me fais honte Alan.
Tu ne connais rien sur rien.
Tu n'es vraiment pas digne de reprendre la société de papa.
Alors là, je peux te dire que j'en connais un rayon sur les chaussettes, alors ne me cherche pas.
Très bien.
Le premier qui n'aura plus rien à dire de pertinent sur les chaussettes,
ne reprendra pas la société de papa.
Défi relevé.
Tu ne me fais pas peur Steven.
Et là?
A peine plus.
Je prends la main.
Je t'en prie.
Quel idiot.
Il n'y a qu'une seule chose à dire sur les chaussettes.
En prenant la main, je gagne forcément.
T'as remarqué que c'est toujours la fois où on met une paire de chaussette trouée...
Que comme par hasard, on se retrouve dans une soirée, où il faut retirer ses chaussures.
Bien observé.
Il est foutu.
Un truc marrant avec les chaussettes...
Hein ?!
C'est qu'elles contiennent 4 tailles en une.
Par exemple, 39 à 42 ou 43 à 46.
Hors, on ne verra jamais un tee-shirt taille S à XL.
Game over, Alan.
Je ne comprends pas de quoi tu parles.
Tu viens de faire une croix sur la société de papa.
Tu ne comprends pas de quoi je parle?
Rassure-moi, tu ne dis pas ça car tu n'as plus rien à dire ?
Comment a-t-il deviné ?!
Non, c'est faux.
J'ai encore pleins de trucs en stock...
Je t'écoute...
Euh... Quel... Quel est le plus bizarre ?
Entre euh....
Porter des chaussettes de sport quand on ne fait pas de sport...
Ou porter des chaussettes de ville quand on vit à la campagne ?
Bonne question tiens...
J'ai eu très, très chaud mais là, il est cuit.
Ce qui est marrant aussi avec les chaussettes...
Non c'est impossible, il n'y a plus rien à dire !
C'est ce phénomène inexplicable de la chaussette qui disparait quand on fait une machine.
Ha ha ha, ce n'est pas du tout pertinent Alan.
Tu penses que cette expérience est universelle, mais elle ne l'est pas.
C'est vrai Steven?
Il y a que toi qui perds une des 2 chaussettes.
Moi même, je n'en ai jamais perdu une seule !
J'étais persuadé que ça arrivait à tout le monde.
La partie est terminée, Alan.
Ceci est faux !
Père Mason?
Et oui...
En tant que proche incontesté de cette famille, je me dois de rétablir la vérité.
Steven est bien le seul à n'avoir jamais perdu de chaussette.
Mais il y a une raison à cela.
Il n'en a jamais porté, et ce depuis le début !
C'est vrai ?
Non il ment !
Tu n'as jamais remarqué qu'il était tout le temps pieds nus?
Mais oui !
C'est pour ça que je ne l'ai jamais vu utilisé un chausse-pieds...
Tout s'explique !
Qui de Alan ou de Steven reprendra l'entreprise familiale ?
Vous le saurez... Pas dans cet épisode, à priori.